foreign  [Music]  [Music]  foreign  [Music]  this all-american group includes a  teacher a nurse  a recording engineer and a photographer  ten years ago they might have stuck to  smoking marijuana  but now they pass around the lines on  the mirror  [Music]  his structure is based on two  foundations  one is extreme violence and the other is  business and logistical organization  his capacity for violence his ambition  and his smarts single him out  and no one actually ever challenges  escobar's leadership  [Music]  planes would leave the jungle drug  laboratories  laden with cocaine and begin to fly  northwards  and hopscotch across the caribbean  before it hit u.s shores  and that was all coming in to miami so  miami was a distribution point  and miami became the hotbed of  corruption  of the cartels  [Music]  you